[Music]
alright guys so you guys know I'm trying
to be so [ __ ] this [ __ ] you look on the
show cuz you have glasses so I'm like
paying attention if you take them off
I'm not gonna pay attention anymore
reporting a lot now you're still funny
just getting the [ __ ] [ __ ] okay wait
take off your glasses and then do it
okay okay yeah yeah yeah I'm not gonna
pay attention at all and put them on
sexy
reporting live oh [ __ ] just kidding news
this is your correspondent Joe Jitsu
coughs speaking today we are gonna be
talking about traveling so we are of the
traveling loving types yeah I think uh
you know I think more than average
meaning like more than before I travel
now much more than I ever did before in
my life yeah thank God I know right it's
[ __ ] awesome I love traveling in 2020
was gonna be my year
everyone's here bro 2020 was my khalil
it's gonna be by your for travel though
okay yeah cuz I I got access to a hookup
which is I travel on standby for free
[ __ ] whose dick did you suck I sucked
some [ __ ] airline dick you know I'm
saying no no I got hooked up I'm super
[ __ ] lucky but I can't use it I can't
use the pass right now cuz you know
traveling is restricted so do you guys
like feel like this whole thing made you
afraid to travel I think I think twice
now about traveling like I don't know
just to even visit my mom I don't know
I'm being in a plane because my buddy in
Vietnam was saying that a girl was
coming back from a fashion show in Italy
and she infected the whole plane oh this
be entire plane the entire plane because
my name is circulation and so the whole
plane was infected with a co vivre
so it kind of scary like yeah because
prior to this whole thing happening like
me and TIFF travel a lot and like every
time we're in a plane like Tiff's like I
know I've never been this way before but
then Tiff's really ingrained in me to be
really paranoid about people coughing
and when when she points it out I'm like
amazed at how many people coughing there
their mouths you know I never pay
attention I do now I'm super sensitive
to that [ __ ] I wouldn't know but I think
people are much better about hovering up
now because you think when people cuff
this way what happens when they're not
wearing a mat it goes up and yeah I
always caught like this anything in this
is all I do in that one guy comes at the
bottom of the shirt what have you like
this your eyeballs pop out yeah I don't
know if that works cause like if someone
nobody's like farting with their pants
down you know and you still smelling it
still comes out you need those smoke
buddies that like people use when they
want to smoke in a place that they're
trying to hide it from just just need a
smoke buddy carry that around oh that's
true five yeah I'm surprised I was
surprised at the time how many people I
noticed were coughing or sneezing with
that really like trying to do anything
about it and they just kind of just do
it out in the open
have you seen those videos where when
they slo-mo a cough or sneeze and then
they show how much space that [ __ ]
covers have you seen that same video but
with the fart camera it shows the hot
heat from the blood cuz the ones that
are the biggest culprit are the [ __ ]
all elderly people because they don't
give a [ __ ]
they're just like I already died people
going on both ends
there's no one's gonna die it's
definitely an elderly people feel like
they're the ones that are least
contagious
yeah I don't know why I'm like getting
[ __ ] from them cuz they're so sweet you
can't carry anything bad and I just I
just think that they're too weak
the germs are old you know like they
cause they're like time travel the
viruses are cold too with you when it
comes to traveling um I'm not really I'm
like scared because I'm scared to be a
carrier for things so I think it is
gonna make me a lot more paranoid and I
do have a trip so I was opposed to
travel a lot this year and all of that
got postponed and I think my the trip is
it got rescheduled for what month are we
in I don't know
we're in March yeah and I'm like kind of
like bug I'm down to do it but I'm just
scared to be a carrier to spread it to
other people like United and American
might even American Airlines are
thinking that it might even be fall oh
my god earliest we're we're normal
travel is resumed yeah normal domestic
travel international travel because
we're seeing waves throughout the world
in different times
Oh kinda happened first and in right now
Europe skating the crazy when I was out
in Austria they immediately reacted
really quick I think the Czech Republic
was the first to close its borders and
do that stuff fast they have a really
low count and then Austria and whatever
and I heard now Austria is right back to
kind of normal but then now we're seeing
it the states and then South America
hasn't really we don't even know what's
happening there yet you know so it's
gonna be like in order so while when
one's recovering one seeing a crazy time
right so like at one part one continent
of the world is gonna be going through
it and the crazy part is because the
United States is so big it's like we
have multiple countries you know the
different parts of the US is blowing up
and then that will calm down different
part blows up and it's like it's like
New York stuff but hotbed right now yeah
exactly
they said we're supposed to have it but
it's really weird how California is
going down because you know California
is supposed to have way more numbers we
only have like 300 deaths in a forty
million populated state which is
extremely low so this is kind of like a
weird anomaly that we're experiencing
but I think it's cuz we're so spread out
we were so much more
they're all in cars I don't walk a
street we're already quarantine you hate
walking here I feel like it's a good
thing though with like people getting
paranoid and practicing proper hygiene
and like being safe because that's what
we all need to do anyway it's not funny
where they're like can you please just
wash your hands and people are like oh
okay
I'll start doing that yeah not only the
the people that work at restaurants but
everyone yeah I didn't wash my hands
that like if I just came home I didn't
just wash my hands because I got home
for sure I never use soap either wait I
didn't use as much should I go for sure
I use a lot more soap I just [ __ ]
rich yeah that's me - what are you doing
it's better than not doing anything but
you should use soap because I thought of
soap as like a degreaser so I was like
if I got my hands dirty I need yeah and
if I just need to wash my hands I just
need to wash my hands you know but now
like now that we're learning a lot more
the capabilities of soap I'm like
alright I can use it up to here yeah
every time I'm singing my ABCs and [ __ ]
like a couple times yeah I did watch a
lot of soap videos though no lie I went
down the rabbit hole
like when soap was invented how soap was
made like they use it he went through
the stoner rabbit hole the stoner and
when I get stoned and I'm like let's
find out about cereal then I'm like
reading about Kellogg's history
so you did that was so that's nice yeah
okay so the the reason why you wanna do
it for 20 seconds is that's how the soap
actually binds to the virus and pulls it
and rips it apart they tell us that they
just they probably do okay it's okay
because regular hand soap if you do it
less than 20 seconds it still binds to
the virus and in it it it holds it and
when you rinse off your hand
it can fall into the sink yeah so if you
guys don't know it's because viruses are
made up of their outer layers like
lipids which are fats and oils so soap
basically breaks apart oil you ever see
like a panel where we drop one drop of
it like explodes out so that's basically
a virus it peels it open so they die you
go down the rabbit hole to you my
girlfriend the chemical engineer so I
mean I know a lot of this stuff too we
talked about like random science that's
pretty hot she always spits out like fun
facts like in like regular conversation
I don't remember what they were but I
just very no but they're very fun like
we went snowboarding and then I forgot
and maybe it was like talking about the
snow or whatever and then she like set a
phone in fact I was like oh cool I'm
like learning other science partners a
problem with them is that they often do
abbreviations for things that you never
used right so one thing she always says
is oh yeah hand me the IPA and I'm like
oh the beer and she's like no the
alcohol has an isopropyl alcohol which
is rubbing alcohol
I'm like no one calls it IPA but you
nerds I'm pale put her in her place man
I feel like I say fun facts I just see
everyone just might do shut the [ __ ] up
nobody cares you're surrounded by a
bunch of meatheads that's true yeah
they're pretty smart uh what fun around
you all this hot out here any fun facts
they don't say them anyone I mean it's
like I don't know anything right now but
it's like [ __ ]
it's literally like the Slumdog
Millionaire thing where it's like if
someone says something and then I'm like
think about my past or like go down like
the rabbit holes of like YouTube videos
and stuff like that and it's like oh my
I know what a pandemic is versus
epidemic you know and then you watch
those videos and like then you know and
what someone says something incorrect
really actually and they're like dude
shut the [ __ ] up oh yeah you come in
[ __ ] snap in your feet standing
corrected you know that's why they're
looking at you like that that's
different than random facts dude random
facts is like oh did you know that this
tissue paper was invented no really for
your nose it was for something you know
and then body originally use this to
[ __ ] wipe the bottom of your kneecaps
or whatever that's like some people say
that's such a stupid way now I'm like
dude no like okay actually it's for this
and then they're like you did say
actually again that's like actually
dumbass that's the guy I did you're like
shut up the deep [ __ ] you yeah trying to
get into deeper say it without actually
the same I'll give you around the fact
like did you know that Nestle water
company was was a was a Nazi company I
just made it up oh well actually it's
not yeah dig yeah I don't know but I
hope that everything resumes quick
because I just love traveling and in
just seeing the world and experiencing
different culture and all that stuff but
also I am gonna be super mindful about
like damn am I gonna get sick every time
I travel now that's true yeah like it's
gonna that paranoia is in the back of my
mind I don't know well I don't I don't
intend on traveling anytime soon just
because my parents are high risk so well
here's the thing at the worst like it
could be a whole year until we return
back to 2019 traveling level the first
thing I'm doing after this is camping so
I'm still alone so screw you guys can't
get you sick
[Music]